foreign
[Music]
to think that the world and
Consciousness are purely material is it
possible for fact checking to be
impartial what makes a scientific theory
successful that should be the Common
Ground here is it correct me if I'm
wrong yeah be sure I will correct you
even if you are right okay
[Music]
the famous philosopher Charles Sanders
purse American philosopher at the end of
the 19th century said that it was a
mistake to try to Define truth but you
could Define the search for truth which
was the search for a point Beyond which
a question is settle the point Beyond
which doubt does not arise
now in the case of Ethics I think there
are plenty of points Beyond which doubt
does not arise if if I ask for a show of
hands how many people in this audience
think that it's wrong to stamp on blind
babies for fun
how many people think it's okay to stamp
on blind babies for fun
there's only about three people put
their hands up
okay so there's a there's something
which is done and dusted it's beyond
discussion to the famous phrase of the
philosopher elizabethanscome if somebody
chooses to the central it he shows a
corrupt mind and I have no interest in
arguing with him in other words it's
something Richard for the moment the
ground stands firm that's where we are
and then you can go on and see if we can
formalize things make more abstract
propositions about morality and so on
and that always proves very difficult
but the basic judgments from which we
start you've got to start in medias
raise in the middle of things and those
basic judgments from which we start like
the one I mentioned those stand firm
those are done and dusted they're part
we can even talk about knowledge if we
wish and where we talk about knowledge
we can talk about objective knowledge
same thing
so I think the
um the polarized debate which Joanna
talked about between relativists on the
one hand and the madman on the other the
Fanatics and the
um uh the totalitarians
um that can be put behind us we've got
to look for more nuanced
issues within the general
sphere of the things we know and the
things we are pretty certain of
and then we can perhaps progress
if you start with the abstract ideas of
objectivity and subjectivity you'll get
nowhere on that note slavoy do you want
to tell us whether objective morality is
possible not in a third world sense but
I still we like I don't know what's
happening with me usually I'm just
butlering around now I'm in a better
mood and I try to find common language
and I still think there is not a big
difference between the two of us yes I
agree with you what you that ultimately
in some sense of course morality
expresses our senses but I would say if
you permit me using one of old examples
of mine that there has to be a minimum
of and very anti-marxist here remarkless
usually attack you know alienation I
think there should be a minimum of
alienation here that I don't present it
just as my expression that's why
here comes my old example phenomena
which always
interested me are this phenomena the
first known example was and I visited
them in south of Greece so-called
weepers
we mean whom you pay to cry for you to
do the morning for you
people claim how hypocritical and so on
now I think this is a positive
phenomenon it gives you a minimum of
distance you minimally objectivize your
stance the same I would say goes now you
will say but this goes for primitive
cultures like you know in ancient China
in Tibet those prayers I love this idea
you put your prayer on a paper you put
the paper in a meal will you turn it
around and put it installing these terms
objectively you are praying even if your
mind is on sex or whatever but now you
will say this for primitive cultures AAA
look at the greatest contribution for me
of American culture in the 20th century
it was so-called canned laughter you
remember it where laughter is part of
the screen it worked with me I often
came home in the evening tired as a dog
I put some stupid series on Cheers
friends and I didn't laugh just like
this but at the end I felt relieved as
if I laughed and I think I don't want to
dismiss this as I know our Marxist
friend will say extreme commodification
racification no there has to be this
minimum of
ritualistic alienation you do a ritual
and I think it was shown I will not take
too much time very briefly it our
reaction to pandemic how this proper
level of minimally objectified morning
didn't function and it was mostly
limited precisely on this hysterical
outbursts on of course on Twitter on
Facebook and so on and so on
so I think Consciousness is um quite a
funny word in some ways
um and I I want to talk about something
that is possibly more tangible but
relates to Consciousness so if we think
of morality for example it's a very
complex behavior that relates to us as
individuals and how we integrate
ourselves within the outer world so when
we study morality as neuroscientists
what we can see is that there's
particular regions particular circuits
within the brain that give rise to our
moral Behavior
and that our genes the DNA that we're
given from our mum and our dad impinge
and underpin our moral code as an
individual but we can also see
that there's quite a lot of different
effects from the environment around us
that can affect how we morally behave
with each other so for example there's
moral contagion if I'm in a group of
people
and these people have different moral
codes different moral values to me then
without me being consciously aware of it
without me realizing I will naturally
start to Veer my moral code and
transgress or increase my moral code
more towards theirs and there's
something really interesting that
happens within our brains as our moral
codes as our moral values get shifted
there's different changes within the
stratum which is a brain region that's
involved in reward and motivation which
means that once you've devalued your
moral code and you're transgressing then
actually your brain gets primed towards
further transgression and to receive
more reward from further transgression
um so this is a really complex aspect of
our Consciousness a very complex
behavioral phenotype of morality
but as neuroscientists start to
understand it a little bit more it's
also posing philosophical questions such
as should we be all taking moral
enhancement agents so agents that would
help us to increase our moral values and
increase our ability to have altruism
and compassion towards other people and
possibly Elevate our consciousness
so I want to start the discussion with
Consciousness by actually reducing it to
a really complex behavior of morality
Consciousness is actually the only thing
that we understand we inhabit it we know
it intimately and in that Descartes was
right that it is one thing we cannot
deny Mata however is a concept that has
been created by our conscious Minds we
know it only as something that we
experience in Consciousness and it's a
construct which is very difficult to
explain it seems to denote a category of
things in Consciousness that resist that
resist my will
of course when you've got things that
don't easily go together one strategy is
just to deny that one of the other one
of the other parties that seem to
conflict exists and this would be the
position of certain sort of philosophers
rather like the church friends and I I
call this the Putin Gambit you know
opposition What opposition
um I don't think it works and uh there
are people of course like Nick Humphrey
who will be talking about his his view
that Consciousness is an illusion
it's an intriguing idea but there is a
problem with that illusion already
suggests Consciousness it begs the
ground of what it's already talking
about how good there's already an
argument
carry on so really essentially what one
needs to be looking at is this
consciousness of something completely
distinct from Mata that super vegans and
some people have suggested that it does
at a certain point in evolution
and their explanations are often
intriguing and complicated but
ultimately unconvincing they boil down
to a kind of hand waving where one
gestures towards some kind of complexity
or some kind of
um transformation that occurs
mysteriously at this point
I prefer the idea which seems to me the
most logical position that if
Consciousness is associated with matter
it doesn't happen at a certain point but
it must be there at some level in some
degree in the business that makes up the
universe and this is a position that's
been reached by a number of the analytic
philosophers of the western tradition
recently including Galen strawson in
England and Christian De Quincy in
America
and essentially that position is that
this is the most rational possible way
of thinking about Consciousness it
doesn't tell us what it is however it
only suggests a way of thinking about it
my own view is that matter is probably a
phase of Consciousness and I'm using the
word phase in the way that chemists and
physicists use it in talking about the
phases of water it can be vaporous it
can be flowing when it's liquid water
and it can be solid when it's ice and it
may be some sort of conduit of
Consciousness but what Consciousness is
I rather think we won't crack I I like
the remark no doubt apocryphal or at
least Anonymous that if our brains were
simple enough for us to understand them
we wouldn't be able to understand
fundamentally we we need a strategy
which as you said raises the living
standards of all of us and creates a
society famously derided by Margaret
Thatcher in a terrible statement there
is no such thing as society and one of
the worst aspects of rentier capitalism
has been over the last 40 years the
systematic plundering of our Commons
those things that belong to all of us
the public amenities the Public Services
the public infrastructure that provide
an informal fabric the poor man's
overcoated sometimes called that
actually helps make Society
one of the symbolic things that Thatcher
did when she became prime minister was
sell off the school playgrounds of our
state schools
and turn it into a profit making
entity
in the austerity era we had a situation
where we were closing thousands of
libraries public libraries to save
public money because of the low taxes
that were creating a budget deficit and
they had to try and make savings you
will see the same thing now
with cuts on public spending because
they've done the tax cuts they've just
done we've got to square the circle so
we've got to get the budget deficit down
so we're cuttings public spending if you
do that you deprive your parks of
Maintenance you deprive your amenities
you privatized your streets and squares
all of this is part of the agenda of
privatization
and in privatizing you deprive Society
of your Social fabric
um in the fake capitalism World in rigor
mortis world you will you will have come
across this a lot I'm sure in uh uh the
media and other things you may have been
reading uh markets are as it were ends
in themselves they're just valuable you
must have things put into a market
um markets are subject to are best
understood as in terms of their freedom
or non-freedom what you want is the
freest possible markets freedom is
understood as the absence of impediment
free markets are markets that are
characterized in the economists
understanding by perfectly by Perfect
information all the information
available is as it were in the price of
whatever the good is
um by Perfect rationality all the agents
involved
um are extreme are perfectly rational
about their own best interests
um and also uh perfect competition so
everyone all these agents are competing
with each other in an entirely
frictionless way that just gives them
maximum opportunity to compete okay so I
think that's a deeply corrupting picture
um in all kinds of different ways
um and there are two or three things
that point just to notice about it the
first is
um that it analogizes everything to
certain kinds of financial markets so it
kind of builds in a mild preference in
favor of financial markets the second is
that it it has a a notion of group
psychology which translates into a
notion of individual psychology on which
individuals are basically economic
automata who are purely motivated by the
desire for gain or the avoidance of loss
okay and the third thing is that when
that's taken it into uh into that's two
further effects well let's take that
idea is taken into government what you
get is a very centralizing government
because it starts to come to see seem to
people in positions of authority as
though the only thing that matters is
whether or not a particular group in
society has had their own economic
incentives appropriately tweaked through
the tax and benefit system so the desire
is but we'll extend the tax and benefit
system to everyone and then if there's a
particular group that isn't being as it
were brought into the system given the
right economic incentives those are
supposed to be the only incentives that
matter we'll just tweak the tax and
benefit system and so you see these
Arguments for people for tax advantaging
marriage or for changing the tax
treatment of
um single mothers or you know you can
see how this kind of thing ramifies
itself and the result of that is a
hideously complex tax and benefit system
which you know very very expert people
struggle to understand if you're
interested in this in the in the uh the
rule the benefits handbook which is the
kind of standard thing uh or uh has
increased from about that big 10 years
ago to about that big
um the tolles manuals of our tax law are
greater than they ever have been I mean
it's just it's a it's a form of insanity
um and we lack the rabbinical scrutiny
in the tax system when our politicians
to allow us to understand how these
things might work and actually people
don't understand it themselves and so of
course their own behavior isn't is
hardly suitable if you can't understand
something it's hard to have have have
your own behavior really affected by it
an effective theory is based on the idea
that at any given time we've measured
certain things in a certain regime of
parameters maybe a certain distance
regime a certain energy regime a certain
um
whatever size regime
um and we can make predictions we can
make successful predictions we can have
theories about that regime of parameters
now to mind you that regime of
parameters becomes bigger and bigger as
we expand our measurements as we look at
more things but we have this very and
and those answers are correct up to the
accuracy with which we've measured
things
so it could be that either by measuring
things more accurately
or by moving to a different regime we
can find that our predictions were not
absolute as you put it they're not
precise but they were precise enough for
everything we had to do precise enough
to send a man to the moon but maybe it
could get more precise and that would be
irrelevant to anything we see today
which is why we're not we haven't
measured that yet now that so I think
it's very comforting and very
comfortable and helps get around a lot
of these silly debates to admit that
that's the way all knowledge works we
based on what we've seen what we've
observed we put it together into
theories we can make predictions science
is unique in that we can usually say the
accuracy with which we trust the
predictions
and then allow things to evolve beyond
that so
to say there's an absolute is
unnecessary in all this we don't even
have to ask that question we have all we
have to do is ask the question is it is
it good enough for what we're trying to
do in whatever we're trying to predict
whatever we're trying to build and
that's the sense in which science is
brilliantly successful and it's also
brilliant and successful in telling us
when we don't have absolute things I
mean what we're doing in particle
physics is we're looking for deviations
from this what we call the standard
model that's what tells us how to go
beyond it doesn't mean the standard
model is wrong it tells us that there
could be a richer structure that
underlies it and that's the way science
can evolve we have a theoretical
framework that we are incredibly
confident works for our own solar system
even up to our own Galaxy so one of the
core tenets of the standard model of
cosmology that we have and that has led
to this old big bang cosmology and all
the uh
all the ideas around it is based on the
implication that what we know of our own
solar system is valid universally across
there are certain base uh like certain
constants that we just assume to be this
we assume the universe to be the same in
all directions we assume gravity to work
the same everywhere
and so one of the interesting things
about how Mond enters the scene is that
this is based on observations that show
actually gravity is not the same
everywhere gravity is actually variable
in certain places now what to do with
that
so what we are discussing with dark
matter Dark Energy these things are they
all come about uh because we have just
assumed at the core that we have a
theory that works for the entire
universe appeal from a philosophical
background do you think that these map
this matters so how we understand how
gravity works and and whether the
current theory is all right in terms of
our philosophical understanding if you
like of the universe and our knowledge
of of it
I mean certainly it matters a lot what
these phenomena are and how uh how we
come about them I mean more I think the
most important part is that uh we don't
see nature or with the universe through
these uh theories in some sort of naked
mathematical way revealed like these are
uh constructions that we have created
over time based on our historical
understanding of how to frame the
problem in the first place so we're
building on initial choices that were
made initial models and then we're
trying to fill them in so I mean one of
the challenges we Face uh in this is we
don't know how far the validity of the
current model in our own solar system
actually extends into the universe so
one of the implications of mind that I
would where does mon like variable
gravity for example come into play like
how far do you have to go out of our
solar system before we could detect by
one standards yeah I think the view
people have is that quantum mechanics is
about small things yeah general
relativity is about big things yeah big
things are made of small things whatever
the small things are the important
things now I think that's wrong quantum
gravity is not the right answer okay so
I'm sticking my neck out here okay the
right answer
there are two different
if you want to combine gravity and
quantum mechanics you have to worry at
least as much
about the effect of gravity on quantum
mechanics as on the effect of quantum
quantum mechanics on gravity people
think oh well if you understand the
theory probably you've got to quantize
it eventually yeah what I'm saying is
that that
isn't it's part of the right answer but
it's not the right answer the right
answer is that quantum mechanics needs
help yes you see quantum mechanics has
an internal
I call it an inconsistency yes the the
people who worried about this most are
Einstein Schrodinger and actually Dirac
the
three of the main figures the subject
and they all for the quantum mechanics
is incomplete yeah or I would say even
inconsistent because the way quantum
mechanics works you just have to go into
the details of this right I don't know
what to do here you
well there's a thing called the
Schrodinger equation which tells you how
a Quantum system evolves in time yeah
and we have lots of evidence that said
yeah it's right
however it's not right as schroding
himself knew and he had this thought
experiment of Schrodinger's cat to draw
rather demonstrate this but if you
follow his equation you get nonsense yes
and that what you to make sense of it
you have to have What's called the
collapse of the wave function that
following the schroding equation doesn't
give you what the world does it's like
yeah we don't see cats that are both
dead and alive we see them very
determinately one thing or the other
that's right you see A or B rather than
sort of A and B at once yeah that sort
of thing and what is it that does that
well my view is it's gravity and that to
fix quantum mechanics which is this very
problem yeah collapse of the wave
function you're going to have to bring
gravity in so you you need to gravitise
quantum mechanics as much as you
quantize gravity and in fact gravitis in
Quantum is the important thing that's
all over the place where it's quantizing
gravity maybe it depends on the
singularities and black holes and all
that stuff but that's only a little tiny
problem yeah the main problem is how to
make Quantum Mechanics Work
we live in a complex
multi-dimensional landscape of risk and
what we're doing all the time is trying
to optimize within this
multi-dimensional landscape of risk
um to find this Optimum to try and live
the richest fullest you know life
possible
and also to discharge our
responsibilities and to honor our social
contracts as best we can within this
very complicated architectural risks now
how do we do that obviously we are not
or we do not
actively see us see ourselves as sort of
constantly engaging in some kind of
dance of trial and error to to reach
that Optimum because some of these
trade-offs have already been worked out
for us by society and by ourselves by
the fact that we've lived lives
so we tend to follow a set of General
guidelines and within which we try and
accommodate our individual preferences
and tolerances but what seems to me that
sometimes in this process and then this
covert incident has really crystallized
for me that we lose sight of these
trade-offs and of the social contract in
which they are embedded I mean it's
clear to me Dave probably won't like
this that unregulated markets can
certainly serve to distort perceptions
of risk of a product or an activity and
also promote expectations of a life
without compromise
um as I'm sure can
um some sort of other authoritarian
framework
but um
that's fundamentally what I think we
should be that's got me thinking is okay
I you know we I think most of us have
accepted that we live within this kind
of really complicated system within
which we're all continuously refining
and changing our ways of dealing with
risk
um and obviously but this whole covet
event has seems to have
um at least presents to me a picture of
people who are not aware of the choices
they're making every day I mean we live
in close association with a multitude of
microorganisms some of which have the
propensity to cause disease and kill us
particularly if we have no previous
acquaintance with them and managing this
ecological relationship is a critical
part of our lives and it requires very
careful thought and in my own work
mathematical models and statistical
methodologies kind of help us determine
the best course of action
um but we what's really important is
that we cannot act along a single
dimension of minimizing risk
um towards a single pathogen one thing
to to perhaps make clear to the audience
is this is happening in everybody in
this room
because we had the pandemic that arrived
with coronavirus now of course we've
fortunately developed vaccines against
the virus and that's been our great
saving uh Grace but what would have
happened anyway with a lot of people
dying of course would have been that our
immune systems would have done exactly
what we're describing that is they would
have used that mechanism for
hypermutating that is mutating extremely
quickly to produce millions of new DNA
sequences and then that is used to be
what then it gives you the immunity the
acquired immunity obviously now what
Richard is questioning is okay maybe
that can occasionally be passed to the
journal line we don't know that yet
whether an immune response can be passed
to the journal line and I would readily
say we don't know that yet but what is
important is Rich's point about how
temporary it is now it's very important
indeed and I agree with Richard about
the importance of temperiness or
permanence because it seems to me that
what these mechanisms give is the option
for The evolutionary process to as it
were try it out if there's an
environmental change that makes it very
difficult to survive and all organisms
are under stress and they alter their
genomes and pass some of that even
temporarily onto the next Generations
what the next Generations can do is to
find out whether they do experience that
change environment or not if they don't
then it's great that it's temporary
you don't have to alter the main genome
if it is more or less permanent and goes
on for many generations then how can it
get assimilated in the genome Conrad
Waddington showed how to do that way
back in the 1950s incidentally his book
the strategy of the genes has been
rightly republished in 2014 so you you
can buy it again it was published in
1957. he did beautiful experiments on
fruit flies he induced changes with very
tiny gentle persuasion as it were from
either heat or ether or some other
experimental techniques in which he
could as he would persuade a few of the
fries to show a new characteristic and
he actually determined how many
generations would you have to continue
to do that in order for it to become
assimilated into the genome it's about
14. it's not very long
now what he was showing is what he
called genetic assimilation I think it
was a great mistake that Waddington was
ignored by The evolutionary biologist
not a shame
[Music]